[Musique]
bonjour à tous si vous nous rejoignez
sur LCP ici à l'Assemblée nationale pour
cette 32e journée du Livre politique
organisé par Luz Perrault à qui nous
devons le bonheur d'être tous ici réunis
alors cette journée se tient ici à
l'Assemblée nationale dans la galerie
des fêtes et à l'hôtel de lacet que nous
retrouvons après quelques années de
covid avec évidemment un immense plaisir
nous allons dans un instant remettre le
Prix étudiant du Livre politique LCP et
le prix étudiant de la BD politique LCP
je vous rappelle que deux auteurs ont
été récompensés ce matin il s'agit de
Franz Olivier Giesbert qui a reçu le
prix des députés pour son livre histoire
intime de la Cinquième République c'est
aux éditions Gallimard et puis Sylviane
à gazinski pour le Prix du Livre
politique pour face à une guerre sainte
aux éditions du Seuil alors pour nous
parler à présent du prix étudiant du
Livre politique LCP je vous demande
d'accueillir give home gauffier Valente
député renaissance du Val-de-Marne et
secrétaire général du jury des députés
[Applaudissements]
merci cher Brigitte Monsieur le Premier
Ministre cher Manuel Valls mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires chers
collègues monsieur le Président de
l'association Lire la société chère
Cédric chère Luce Mesdames et Messieurs
les réseaux sociaux alliés ou ennemis de
la démocratie ces technologies ces
outils de communication d'échange
d'organisation ont pris une place
considérable dans nos vies et dans notre
société au cours des dernières années
les questionnements qui entourent leur
régulation leur fonctionnement les
conséquences de leurs usages sont
nombreuses et je salue le fait que nous
ayons décidé d'organiser ces 32e journée
du Livre Politique sur ce thème au
moment où nous arrivons à la fin de nos
échanges je tiens à remercier chacune et
chacun des intervenants pour leurs
interventions et
le partage de leurs expertises de leur
regard sur l'impact des réseaux sociaux
sur notre démocratie de leur impact sur
notre société sur notre vibrant ensemble
sur notre société sociabilité comme le
disait il y a un instant Jérémy
Pelletier
sur ces technologies que
nous utilisons mais que nous ne
maîtrisons pas en réalité je tiens aussi
bien entendu à saluer l'US Perrault et
l'ensemble de ses équipes et je pense
que nous pouvons applaudir plus parce
que vous êtes nombreux aujourd'hui
présent que c'est des heures et des
heures tout au long de l'année de
travail et d'engagement d'engagement
pour notre démocratie merci cher Luce le
choix de ce thème cette année le fruit
de multiples échanges au cours de l'été
dernier sur les évolutions de la vie
politique que nous connaissons sur les
événements internationaux aussi la
révolution en Iran notamment suite à
l'assassinat de Macha bien entendu
auquel je pense mais aussi au départ
d'un livre et d'un auteur le livre le
mage du Kremlin l'auteur Giuliano
dampoli un livre qui joue le sait nous a
beaucoup marqué les uns et les autres et
interpeller l'auteur il démontre avec
finesse et précision
les ressorts et les forces de la
construction du régime autocratique
russe de Vladimir Poutine il y explique
remarquablement bien l'utilisation qui
est faite des nouveaux outils numériques
mais avant cet ouvrage et Monsieur le
Premier Ministre germanuel vous l'avez
cité tout à l'heure il y avait un autre
ouvrage du maître moteur un ouvrage à
mettre dans toutes les mains les
ingénieurs du chaos le retour
d'expérience du mouvement 5 étoiles et
de la présidence de Donald Trump
l'explication minutieuse de l'importance
qu'on jouait les réseaux sociaux et de
la maîtrise de la data dans la
déstabilisation de la vie politique de
deux états l'Italie et les États-Unis et
dans la conquête du pouvoir le rôle clé
de l'alliance entre ceux qui maîtrisent
parfaitement cette technologie et le fou
du peuple populiste
conservateur prêt à tout pour renverser
la table grâce à ses outils un livre qui
nous démontre l'impact considérable que
peuvent avoir les réseaux sociaux sur le
fonctionnement de nos démocraties
ces réseaux ces outils permettent à
diffuser permettent de diffuser très
largement des informations permettent la
communication institutionnelle permet de
renforcer l'accès à l'information ils
sont des outils de mobilisation durant
les révolutions du prétend à aujourd'hui
encore en Iran pour la contestation
contre des régimes qui tiranisent leur
population ils sont des vecteurs
d'expression de sensations et d'émotions
de solidarité mais ils sont aussi dans
leur phase la plus sombre des outils
d'expression de frustration de haine de
colère de racisme d'antisémitisme
d'homophobie de misogynie d'anti
parlementarisme des outils de
harcèlement numérique et bien d'autres
choses encore des outils de contrôle des
citoyens de leur représentants
des outils au service d'une dictature de
la communication du CLIC et du poste au
détriment du temps de la réflexion et de
la nuance bref des outils qui posent
question ces outils soulèvent des
questionnements qui appellent de notre
part des réponses afin qu'ils
fonctionnent dans le respect des règles
de notre République ce qui n'est pas
autorisé dans la vie réelle ne doit pas
l'être dans la vie numérique sur les
réseaux sociaux ou Internet nous
disaient tout à l'heure mon ancienne
collègue Laetitia avia et donc ces
outils il nous faut les réguler ainsi
que leur comportement et Caroline forest
nous alerter dessus il y a quelques
instants pour cela nous devons fixer et
bien
des repères pour reprendre tes mots à
Charlus ce que tu nous a partagé la
semaine dernière auprès des collègues
qui participent au prix du Livre
politique c'est ce que nous faisons ici
sur cette journée tout au long de
l'année à travers les différents prix
des livres politiques et des députés
nous fixons des repères et nous
transmettons la culture française
et ces points de repères nous avons
construit tout au long de la journée
notamment à travers quatre tables rondes
afin de définir ce que sont les réseaux
sociaux afin de regarder leur impact sur
les cybercriminalités afin d'étudier les
addictions qu'elle crée mais également
enfin de voir qu'est-ce qu'elles peuvent
apporter à notre démocratie mais
réflexions que nous avons menées
mesdames et messieurs je vous propose
que nous les gardions à l'esprit en tant
que législateur elles sont en nature à
alimenter nos travaux les travaux que
nous menons à l'Assemblée nationale dans
ce lieu qui est le cœur battant de notre
démocratie dans ce lieu où se construit
la légitimité des lois qui régissent la
vie de notre société légitimité qu'il
nous faut aujourd'hui rappeler et
défendre contre toutes celles et tous
ceux qui veulent l'abattre au nom du
peuple ces repères cette culture nous
devons les transmettre bien entendu le
temps du clic ne doit jamais prendre le
pas sur celui de la réflexion c'est tout
le sens du dernier prix de cette journée
le prix du livre étudiant
dans quelques instants nous allons le
remettre à un prix à la symbolique
particulièrement forte un prix qui se
veut être le passage de témoin entre les
générations et la construction de
l'avenir le livre est encore l'objet je
pense le plus puissant pour décortiquer
les réalités de notre société et tenter
d'y apporter des éléments de réponse de
compréhension d'amélioration de notre
vivre ensemble ne l'oublions jamais
est-ce que les réseaux sociaux et le
Mettet un verre
sont un allié de notre démocratie la
question est posée elle demeure bien
entendu à la fin de cette journée le
livre lui en est un incontestable il en
est même un des socles fondateurs et
libérateurs alors Mesdames et Messieurs
continuons de lire lisons lisons lisons
et des bâtons encore merci
[Applaudissements]
merci
introduction alors nous allons
évidemment remettre le Prix étudiant du
Livre politique LCP et le prix étudiant
de la BD politique LCP une particularité
pour ces deux prix ça ne vous aura pas
échappé ils sont tous les deux en
partenariat avec LCP une initiative du
président Bertrand delay qui va nous
expliquer tout de suite ce choix
merci Brigitte
mesdames messieurs Monsieur le Premier
Ministre d'abord mesdames et messieurs
les députés
mesdames Messieurs chers Luce
depuis 4 ans maintenant elle s'est fait
effectivement partenaire de la Journée
du Livre politique et promoteur du prix
étudiant du Livre politique comme ça
vient d'être dit c'est un pari de ça
veut dire transfert entre les
générations mais d'abord je voudrais
remercier très chaleureusement les
étudiantes et étudiants qui cette année
encore se sont en nombre investis avec
sérieux les débats ont été riches et
passionnés et contradictoires je tiens à
le dire aussi je tiens à remercier
Géraldine Baillet la présidente du jury
et Luz pero qui avec une énergie
infatigable fait vivre cet événement
alors si la Chaîne parlementaire a
choisi d'accompagner cet événement c'est
pour deux raisons complémentaires
d'abord je le dis et le répète
inlassablement depuis que je dirige la
chaîne
je pense qu'au moment où la société
française est tentée par la dislocation
il appartient à un média de service
public d'être un acteur pour essayer de
reconstruire un commun et considérer que
nous sommes ce qui nous rassemble nous
tous aujourd'hui doit être plus
important que ce qui nous singularise et
à l'heure des réseaux sociaux et de leur
effet loupe c'est effectivement un pari
et un engagement et de ce point de vue
parler à la jeunesse ou offrir un prix à
la jeunesse c'est quelque chose
d'important et c'est aussi une nécessité
pour nous chaîne de télévision de
toucher un public plus jeune autrement
que par la diffusion télé classique avec
plus aujourd'hui de cent mille abonnés
sur Youtube près de 700 000 followers
sur Twitter LCP cherche à intéresser
davantage la jeunesse au nom de sa
mission citoyenne et dans ces conditions
il était naturel aussi dans la stratégie
qu'on appelle orecran qui est la nôtre
de participer à la création de ce prix
c'est être au cœur de notre mission
citoyenne
[Applaudissements]
alors nous allons maintenant procéder à
la remise du Prix étudiant du Livre
politique LCP je vous annonce les trois
finalistes alors Azzedine Ahmed Chaouch
et Valentin Pasquier pour dossier
maîtresse chez plomb
[Applaudissements]
Bertrand Perrier et Guillaume Prigent
pour débattre une valeur en voie de
disparition chez Flammarion
[Applaudissements]
et Hervé le bras pour tableau historique
de la France aux éditions du Seuil
[Applaudissements]
alors le jury va vous présenter
évidemment ses livres Raphaël tricot qui
est membre du jury du Prix étudiant du
Livre politique LCP van nous rejoindre
je lui demande de devenir sur scène
ainsi qu'à Zidane chez Valentin Pasquier
Raphaël tricot vous nous présentez donc
ce premier ouvrage de cv13 et c'est chez
plomb
merci Madame boucher bonjour à toutes et
à tous c'est vraiment un honneur de
pouvoir m'exprimer aujourd'hui de devant
vous
pour pouvoir vous parler très rapidement
de cet ouvrage qui m'a particulièrement
touché qui retrace le procès de 9 mois
donc des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
une chose c'est qu'il déjà pourquoi il
m'a touché c'est il porte une charge
émotionnelle bouleversante c'est faut
vraiment avoir le cœur accroché pour se
plonger dans ce livre c'est une lecture
très immersive il a la particularité
d'être un roman graphique et donc les
aquarelles et les illustrations
deviennent un vrai matériau un vrai
matériau journalistique à part entière
et quand on tient en fait ce livre entre
les mains on a vraiment l'impression de
tenir le dossier V13 d'accéder à toutes
ces tous ces détails et on porte aussi
le chagrin la l'incompréhension des
familles de victimes on porte aussi le
traumatisme des rescapés des forces de
l'ordre qui vont arriver sur des scènes
de crimes et découvrir des scènes de
crimes d'une atrocité sans nom mais
c'est un livre donc certes c'est un
livre politique mais c'est aussi un
livre historique un outil je pense pour
l'histoire pour la mémoire et c'est
aussi avant tout un livre très humain
mais qui ne va pas tomber dans une dans
un pathos un solvable je trouve qu'il
porte un message un beau message
d'espoir et de confiance en la justice
française pour combattre le terrorisme
et son efficacité à émettre des
sanctions qui sont juste dans le sens où
elles ne vont pas tomber dans la cruauté
et l'inhumanité des actes qu'elle juge
et qui donc ces sanctions qui ne vont
pas non plus céder à la facilité et la
perversion de d'un certain esprit de
vengeance qui qu'on pourrait avoir à
prendre personnellement ces attaques
terroristes voilà merci de m'avoir
écouté
[Applaudissements]
deuxième finaliste à présent pour donc
Bertrand Périé Guillaume Prigent qui
vont venir nous rejoindre pour débattre
une valeur en voie de disparition chez
Flammarion et c'est un autre membre du
jury du Prix étudiant qui va vous le
présenter c'est Quentin savant voilà
venez me rejoindre et vous aussi
finaliste donc de ce prix étudiant du
Livre politique
bonjour à tous Tout d'abord merci de me
donner l'occasion de présenter présenter
ce livre débattre une valeur en voie de
disparition de Guillaume Prigent et
Bertrand Perrier donc c'est un ouvrage
qui prend la forme d'un essai argumenté
très très rigoureux construit de façon
presque scientifique qui donc détaille
les problématiques que connaissent le
débat public aujourd'hui mais j'ai
beaucoup aimé le fait que il y a aussi
des pistes de solutions qui soient
proposées à destination des citoyens
tout comme du personnel politique donc
c'est une plus-value qui permet à
l'ouvrage de dépasser la simple analyse
sociétale et au lecteur de ressortir en
quelque sorte optimiste de sa lecture
j'ai bien nommé aussi l'arc que
l'argument l'argumentation soit appuyée
par des exemples de la vie de la vie
quotidienne parfois on se reconnaît dans
les descriptions de débat avec ses
proches ou au fil de la lecture en
réalise
pense que inconsciemment une
introspection sur sur soi-même
donc voilà quoi que l'on pense des
détails qui sont exposés dans un
contexte où notre société apparaît
particulièrement fracturée polarisé dans
dans un contexte comme ça de Chris
social et politique je trouve que c'est
particulièrement important de pouvoir
réapprendre à débattre correctement pour
retrouver un débat fertile et
constructif voilà donc merci de m'avoir
écouté
[Applaudissements]
dernier finaliste à présent et j'appelle
victoire
long à nous rejoindre les membres du
jury du Prix étudiant du Livre politique
LCP elle va nous présenter le livre
d'Hervé Le Bras si vous voulez nous
rejoindre monsieur le bras aussi donc ce
tableau historique de la France aux
éditions du Seuil je vous laisse la
parole
bonjour à tous Le l'ouvrage d'Hervé Le
Bras nous a tous beaucoup plus malgré sa
complexité et peut-être justement en
raison de sa complexité puisqu'il se
proposait
d'expliquer les dynamiques politiques à
l'oeuvre non seulement non plus
seulement
à la lumière de de la classe sociale des
citoyens de leur ancrage social mais
aussi à la lumière de leur ancrage
géographique et c'est à la croisée de
l'histoire de la géographie et de la
sociologie et c'est ce qui en fait un
ouvrage à la fois parfois un peu
complexe à lire mais aussi très original
les particulièrement intéressant et nous
sommes nous étions tous unanimes pour
dire que c'est un ouvrage qui fera
probablement date pour les années à
venir merci beaucoup
et merci à vous alors les délibérations
ont eu lieu il est toujours
effectivement difficile de départager
ces livres puisqu'ils ont tous les trois
été sélectionnés donc ce sont tous les
trois d'excellents ouvrages mais il faut
un vainqueur alors je vais demander à
Bertrand Dolet de nous rejoindre
président du jury du Prix étudiant du
Livre politique LCP pour remettre ce
prix
c'est pas comme au César j'ai pas une
enveloppe alors
le vainqueur ou plutôt les vainqueurs et
donc là je dévoile déjà un peu quelque
chose c'est dossiers V13 d'azedine Ahmed
Chaouche et de Valentin Pasquier alors
[Applaudissements]
je dois dire
qu'on a été assez le vote n'a pas été
unanimé la vie sur la qualité
exceptionnelle du travail qui est une
vraie somme autour de ce procès que vous
avez fait là était unanime je tiens à le
dire et la deuxième chose c'est que je
trouve là que c'est très fort que ce
soit le prix étudiant sur ce livre parce
que comme l'avait dit en son temps
Manuel Valls lorsqu'il était Premier
ministre le défi de la jeunesse c'est
l'environnement mais c'est aussi la
montée de l'intégrisme islamique et du
séparatisme dans la République et de ce
point de vue cet ouvrage dans la façon
même dont il est construit puisque on
prend les acteurs et on les dissèque un
peu à la manière d'un entomologiste on
va dire ça comme ça je pense que c'est
cet ouvrage est un ouvrage de référence
voilà bravo à vous
[Applaudissements]
merci déjà c'est la première des choses
et sincèrement je suis
très très fier parce que la fin de
recevoir ce prix étudiant étudiant parce
que la transmission quand on s'est mis
d'accord pour réaliser cet ouvrage la
transmission elle a été au cœur en fait
de notre motivation comment rendre
compte de manière efficace au plus grand
nombre de cet événement historique hors
norme avec des débats puissants des
témoignages forts avec des décryptages
de policiers de politique avec des
accusés qui n'avaient jamais parlé
comment ça on pouvait le le graver en
quelque sorte dans le marbre dans
l'histoire peut-être modestement il y
avait évidemment le l'écrit mais le
récit graphique nous paraissait la
manière la plus
oui efficace parce que déjà un par
définition dans les procès il y a pas de
photo il y a pas d'image et de
on a été traversé par d'incroyables
émotions on a parfois ri ça nous est
arrivé on a parfois pleuré on a beaucoup
appris voilà et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est aussi particulier parce que j'ai
face à moi un Premier ministre qui était
au premier horloge lors de l'heure de
ses crises donc
je suis vraiment ému et pour terminer
j'aimerais peut-être avoir une remarque
plus personnelle sur la justice
effectivement alors où on l'a décrit où
elle est critiqué trop laxiste ou
politique là je trouve que elle a
pendant 9 mois dix mois montrer que face
à l'horreur face à la terreur ni avec
une seule manière de répondre c'était de
rester elle-même et de ne pas se trahir
en appliquant le droit le droit et rien
que le droit voilà
pareil cassedine je voulais vous
remercier en tout cas enfin c'est la
vraiment une grande surprise si j'avais
su j'aurais passé une veste ou j'aurais
vouloir passer ma chemise
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une grande
surprise je voulais remercier le jury en
tout cas tous les tous les retours qu'on
a eu sur sur ce livre merci à Azdine
voilà on a travaillé en bon intelligence
en dialogue lui sur les textes moi sur
les dessins et merci aux équipes de
plomb aussi pour le voilà l'objet avec
qui donne une grande place une grande
place au dessin
cet objet qu'on a voulu vraiment hybride
entre le voilà à mi-chemin entre le
littéraire le graphique et j'espère
qu'avec ce voilà ce prix nous conforte
un petit peu dans cette idée là mais
j'espère qu'avec ce modeste livre on a
voilà on a été à la hauteur de tout ce
qui s'est raconté lors de ce procès et
voilà je vous remercie encore
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous et bravo donc pour ce prix
remis à Valentin Pasquier pour dossier
V13 félicitations à vous nous allons je
vais vous demander de regagner la salle
si s'il vous plaît nous allons à présent
procéder à la à la remise du dernier
prix las buts le prix étudiant de la BD
politique toujours en partenariat avec
LCP et voici donc les trois finalistes
alors Annick Cojean et Sandrine Revel
pour une farouche liberté Gisèle Halimi
la cause des femmes chez stenkis
[Applaudissements]
Laurent Frédéric Bollé et Jeanne Puchol
pour Malikou sekin contre coup aux
éditions Casterman
[Applaudissements]
et Emmanuel Marie et Samuel fillgaire et
Valette pour terre d'accueil de famille
de parcours un espoir chez petit à petit
[Applaudissements]
alors les membres du jury du Prix
étudiant de la BD politique LCP vont me
rejoindre j'appelle d'abord myvelt à
monter sur scène ainsi que Nicko Jean et
Sandrine Revel maëvael vous allez nous
présenter donc ce premier ouvrage celui
d'une farouche liberté Gisèle allait mis
la cause des femmes
bonjour merci de m'accueillir ici
madame Cojean madame couturier merci
merci pour votre oeuvre qui répond à un
devoir de mémoire à l'égard de Gisèle
Halimi trois ans après sa disparition
une farouche liberté pour celles et ceux
qui ne l'ont pas encore lu est une bande
dessinée d'espoir
d'espoir par la beauté de ces dessins
lumineux c'était ça inspire l'espoir
malgré la dureté des sujets qu'ils
inspirent
d'espoir pour le thème qu'elle porte la
cause des femmes le combat pour le droit
à l'avortement la répression du viol la
parité
la défense des militants et militantes
pour l'indépendance de la Tunisie et de
l'Algérie et bien d'autres sujets encore
d'espoir pour cette farouche liberté
finalement ce combat pour ce qui est
juste et légitime et non ce qui est
strictement légal
j'ai redécouvert ici Gisèle Halimi je la
connaissais pour son combat pour le
droit à l'avortement pour sa victoire
lors du procès de Marie-Claire pour sa
participation Manifeste des 343
et puis c'était tout
et puis je l'ai redécouverte son enfant
c'est brillantes études son combat
contre les violences commises par
l'armée française lors de la guerre
d'Algérie
alors merci de m'avoir permis cela de
nous rappeler trois ans après son décès
à quel point la force de son combat
résonne toujours aujourd'hui plus que
jamais
vous parlez en quatrième de couverture
de sa volonté de transmettre aux
nouvelles générations le flambeau de la
révolte j'aimerais ajouter cette phrase
que je tire de votre ouvrage vous
souriez le monde ne vous paraît toujours
pas juste c'est vrai je ne me résigne
pas et compte sur vous pour ce combat
alors nous espérons que nous nouvelle
génération que nous représentons
préétudiants du Livre politique et de la
bande dessinée politique continueront à
mener notre combat pour ce qui est juste
sans jamais se résigner pour Gisèle à la
limite pour tous celles et ceux qui
avant elle on fait le choix de porter la
justice au cœur de leur vie
aujourd'hui plus que jamais dans ce
contexte social je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
un autre membre du jury va venir nous
rejoindre à présent il s'agisse de Louis
Sastre pour nous présenter le deuxième
finaliste l'oeil deuxième finaliste
Laurent Frédéric Bollé et Jeanne Puchol
qui viennent aussi sur scène pour
Malikou sekin contre coup aux éditions
Casterman Louis Sastre vous avez la
parole
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre bonjour à toutes et
tous je suis très heureux de prendre la
parole pour faire l'éloge de cette
excellente bande dessinée qui est
Malikou c'est qui contrecoup publié en
octobre 2022 les auteurs Madame pucholle
et Monsieur bolet retrace dans cet
ouvrage l'itinéraire de manicusicine ce
gène étudiant de 22 ans qui sera frappé
mortellement par trois policiers le soir
la nuit du 6 décembre 1986
son tort à vrai dire il en avait pas
vraiment simplement de se trouver aux
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment depuis
quelques jours des étudiants
manifestaient contre le projet de la loi
de vaquer lui il ne manifestait pas il
sortait simplement d'un club de jazz du
quartier latin il fut pourtant pris en
chasse par des brigadiers voltigeur
jusque dans le hall d'un immeuble là-bas
il fut frappé à de nombreuses reprises
il fut frappé à mort cette histoire
dramatique nous la connaissons tous elle
nous rappelle à quel point la violence
est inacceptable dans notre société
c'est pourquoi nous avons un véritable
devoir de mémoire au sujet de l'affaire
malikouzekin madame Puchol monsieur
bolet par votre BD vous nous permettez
de réaliser ce devoir vous le faites
avec brio le lecteur peut se replonger
dans cette sombre histoire qui a marqué
durablement l'opinion publique en
faisant le choix du noir et blanc vous
nous donnez une certaine austérité à vos
planches nul doute que ces derniers ont
été faites j'ose le dire à dessin cela
renforce la profondeur et la gravité de
votre ouvrage
au-delà la narration que vous faites
participent également à la qualité de
votre bande dessinée d'abord l'hommage
que vous lui rendez dans les premières
pages et vibrants quel aurait été
l'avenir de malicou Sékine s'il n'avait
pas croisé la route de ces policiers
nous ne le serons malheureusement jamais
cette manière de passer d'un personnage
à l'autre tiens le lecteur en haleine
tout le long inéluctablement il sent le
drame venir ce drame qui emporte alors
tous les personnages dans un engrenage
dont ils ne peuvent sortir je tiens à le
dire l'ensemble du jury a été captivé
par cette narration en remettant sous le
feu des projecteurs la ferme malicuskin
vous permettait ainsi une nouvelle
génération la mienne de s'approprier un
tel sujet nous en sommes reconnaissants
nous sommes convaincus que sa mémoire
doit être entretenue votre bande
dessinée est participantement c'est
pourquoi au-delà de ses qualités
textuelles et graphiques nous l'avons
sélectionné parmi les trois finalistes
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
et nous allons maintenant vous présenter
le dernier finalisme alors j'appelle
Louise le stom membre du jury du Prix
étudiant de la BD politique LCP et
Emmanuel Marie et Samuel figuier à venir
nous rejoindre ici pour ce livre que
vous allez nous présenter donc terre
d'accueil de famille de parcours et un
espoir
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis très
honorée de vous présenter cette bande
dessinée
pour commencer pour vous par vous citer
il rêve d'un ailleurs et vont
entreprendre le périple le plus
dangereux dans l'espoir d'une vie
meilleure à travers le récit de deux
familles qui tendent leur pays d'origine
vers un horizon plein d'espoir la bande
dessinée terre d'accueil propose une
réflexion sur l'accueil des migrants en
Europe
réalisé en collaboration avec le projet
de recherche haricot sur l'accueil des
réfugiés en Europe cet ouvrage est aussi
un projet pédagogique pour apporter un
regard sur l'histoire et l'actualité
éclairer les récits des personnes
exilées pour sortir des chiffres et des
statistiques pour mettre des visages et
des noms sur l'exil pour humaniser
l'immigration
les protagonistes ne sont pas simplement
des immigrés ils sont Naïa
IBA Demba et Hamadi et il fut la guerre
civile ou la misère en quittant leur
pays vers l'inconnu
terre d'accueil et construite autour de
l'idée que la dignité humaine et la
fraternité sont des principes
fondamentaux qui doivent garantir
l'accueil des personnes exilées quel que
soit leurs origines elle est aussi un
hommage à toutes les victimes des
dangers rencontrées sur les chemins de
l'exil enfin plus qu'une bande dessinée
terre d'accueil est un message politique
un message de tolérance et d'humanisme
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
alors vous connaissez désormais mieux
les trois finalistes du Prix étudiant de
la BD politique LCP et je vais appeler
la présidente du jury Géraldine Bannier
à nous rejoindre pour nous expliquer les
délibérations et surtout lever le
suspense sur le lauréat merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
alors madame la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche monsieur le Président de lire
la société
il y a plus de collègues députés mais je
salue malgré tout mes collègues et je
salue évidemment tout ceux qui sont dans
la salle qui sont évidemment des
lecteurs
il s'appelle Alexis Alexane Ilan jade
Louis Louise Maé Quentin Raphaël Salomé
et victoire ils ont été pendant les
délibérations assidues convaincu
convaincant souriant et pour tout dire
et pas tant je suis très très fière
d'avoir accompagné ces étudiants pendant
les délibérations et notamment pour le
prix de la BD parce que moi je suis pas
une grande dessinatrice donc j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour tous les
dessinateurs je remercie infiniment
infiniment Luce d'associer ainsi depuis
2015 des étudiants Masters en première
année de doctorat cette Journée du Livre
politique je crois que l'idée de
transmission a été le moteur de les
initiale de Luce il y a 32 ans de créer
cette Journée du Livre politique
la bande dessinée c'est évidemment un
vecteur excellent pour partager
vulgariser des sujets parfois ardues et
je vous n'aurez pas de surprise le choix
n'a pas été facile au dire des étudiants
les trois ouvrages finalistes véhiculent
trois messages très différents
tout c'est important et dans des formes
assez différentes
on a d'un côté l'innocence d'un avenir
prometteur tragiquement brisé
le refus de l'assignation d'une femme au
combat multiple exemplaire
les parcours sur le fil si difficile de
migrants
et je crois que je dois annoncer le
vainqueur
l'ouvrage qui gagne cette année je vais
reprendre les mots de l'étudiant tout à
l'heure je vais reprendre les mots
d'austérité brio narration profondeur et
bien c'est Malik ou c'est Kin de Jeanne
Puchol et Laurent Frédéric bolet
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
mesdames et messieurs merci vraiment
beaucoup au jury à cette belle
organisation et assez ce grand honneur
et cette fierté que nous ressentons bien
évidemment à cette annonce je m'adresse
malgré tout à nos compétiteurs en leur
disant que leurs livres sont formidables
et aurait tout aussi bien mérité d'être
à notre place en ce moment même c'est
une évidence et bravo à vous bien sûr je
remercie mon éditeur Casterman qui avait
pris un certain risque parce que
figurez-vous qu'il a pu nous entendre on
a pu nous dire parfois que ça remontait
à plus de 30 ans cette histoire et que
peut-être plus personne s'en souvenait
que c'était peut-être un peu loin que
c'était peut-être pas un très bon sujet
voyez donc merci de remettre quand même
cette lumière sur Malikou c'est Kin je
remercie beaucoup Jeanne évidemment
parce que en tant que scénariste vous
savez que on écrit d'abord un petit peu
les textes on se projette dans son
propre livre on se fait un peu son film
avant mais la magie de ce métier de
scénariste c'est que lorsque les images
sont vraiment réalisées elles sont
toujours beaucoup plus fortes que celles
qu'on avait imaginé et là je peux dire
que Jeanne ça a été le cas car ton noir
et blanc est tellement impactant et
tellement fort qu'effectivement ce livre
aussitôt acquis une dimension que
j'espérais mais qui est qui je pense le
cas
mes pensées iront bien évidemment
amalikou c'est Kim vous vous en doutez
ce jeune homme de 22 ans
étudiant qui ce jour là ce soir-là est
sorti au Quartier Latin c'est toujours
pas vraiment pourquoi le fait-il qu'il
était au Quartier Latin qu'il ne
manifestait pas et qu'il se retrouvait
l'expression a été employée
effectivement au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment et qu'il a donc été battu
à mort tel un animal dans le hall
d'animuble et moi à cette époque là j'ai
18 ans et je me réveille le lendemain
matin je ne suis pas dans les rues non
plus je me réveille le lendemain matin
et j'apprends cette mort évidemment que
je ressens aussitôt comme scandaleuse
voyez 30 ans après plus de 30 ans après
36 ans après
j'y pense encore je crois sincèrement
que cette histoire m'a fait rentrer dans
une certaine forme d'adulte j'étais
jeune peut-être insouciant ce jour-là en
une journée j'ai grandi d'un coup et le
lendemain matin je n'étais plus tout à
fait le même avec un éveil à une
certaine conscience politique sociétale
qui fait qu'effectivement faut parler de
certaines choses
l'actualité veut que depuis hier
quelques pelotons motorisés de policiers
à moto soit au plein centre de
l'actualité donc là c'est vraiment sans
doute là aussi le hasard mais gardons
donc à l'esprit que le pvm en 86 ou la
Bravet de nos jours soit source quand
même d'amélioration ou en tout cas au
moins de vigilance voire de dénonciation
voilà je n'irai pas plus loin merci à
vous et je vais laisser la parole à
Jeanne merci beaucoup c'est un honneur
bonjour et donc
Laurent Frédéric a tout dit c'est normal
c'est lu le scénariste c'est lui qui
écrit moi je dessine
donc je ne vais pas redire tout ce qu'il
a dit si bien je voudrais juste ajouter
que personnellement ça me touchait
énormément ce prix décerné par des
étudiants et des étudiants puisque ces
deux et d'elle que nous parlons dans
notre livre que la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui
voilà soit touchée par cette histoire de
la jeunesse d'hier évidemment c'est
c'est très très important cette jeunesse
qui défie à nouveau aujourd'hui et en
1986 il avait fallu la mort de Malikou
Sekine pour que monsieur de vaquer
retire son projet de loi j'espère qu'il
ne faudra pas en arriver à de telles
extrémités aujourd'hui pour que la
situation actuelle connaisse une issue
favorable
quoi qu'il en soit qu'est-ce que je
voulais dire d'autre j'ai oublié
non bon voilà c'était ça le plus
important oui d'une part donc ne pas en
arriver là pour que la situation évolue
dans le bon sens et aussi puisqu'on est
dans cet endroit à l'Assemblée nationale
ce que je souhaite ardemment c'est que
les députés les parlementaires
retrouvent leur plein rôle ce pourquoi
nous les avons élus merci
[Applaudissements]
merci donc félicitations à vous Laurent
Frédéric Bollé et Jeanne pucholle pour
Malik ou c'est Kin contre coup aux
éditions Casterman et qui remporte le
Prix étudiant de la BD politique pour
conclure la cérémonie de remise des prix
étudiants et de prix du Livre politique
à l'Assemblée nationale je vais demander
à Sylvie Retailleau ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche de nous rejoindre
alors Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires je ne sais pas s'il y en
a mais en tout cas madame la députée
chère Géraldine Monsieur le Directeur
Général cher Monsieur Bertrand delay
d'abord mesdames et messieurs les
membres du jury ce que j'aime vous
appeler comme ça chers étudiants et
chers étudiants chers tous et toutes et
comme Gérald du lundi cher lecteur
Charlie sperrot alors je ne cache pas
mon plaisir d'être ici c'est à la fois
un plaisir et un honneur d'être ici avec
vous aujourd'hui pour clôturer cette
très belle journée d'échange et surtout
cette remise du Prix étudiant du Livre
politique alors c'est important c'est
important pour l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche c'est important pour sa
ministre mais ce qui est important c'est
pour la jeunesse pour ses étudiants qui
sont présents ici et qui le portent haut
et fort aujourd'hui et je voudrais
d'abord vous en remercier avant de
parler des lauréat avant de parler du
livre evidemment cette initiative
entreprise nous réunit aujourd'hui ça
aussi c'est quelque chose de fort autour
du livre et qui vise à encourager et je
dirais à favoriser l'accès au débat
d'idées au débat d'idées pour tous et
pour toutes et à renouveler réaffirmer
ce lien ce lien que l'on doit garder ce
lien que l'on doit renforcer entre les
citoyens et leurs institutions et la
politique y est un outil je tiens à
saluer tout particulièrement aussi vous
vous en doutez l'association d'étudiants
et d'étudiantes à cette démarche et je
voudrais qu'elle dire quelques mots
parce que pour moi former former c'est
d'abord former des citoyens éclairés et
c'est d'abord ce rôle de mon ministère
du ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur
et de la Recherche et de l'ensemble des
établissements je crois que dans le
monde entier c'est une des plus belles
missions que l'on peut avoir
peut-être des plus difficiles aussi
aujourd'hui au 21e siècle mais des plus
nobles de participer à former ces
citoyens éclairés alors on l'a dit
depuis que ce matin je l'ai entendu
depuis que je suis ici l'actualité
récente ou l'actualité nous montre à
quel point à quel point nous avons
besoin de cette parole je dirais cette
parole scientifique avec un grand test
de toutes les sciences et la
connaissance dans le débat public on l'a
vu tout à l'heure c'est fausses
informations qui sont parfois
effectivement je reprends si facile à
créer
si facile à faire circuler vite et
facilement mais une information
scientifique avec un grand S de toutes
les sciences elle lorsqu'elle est de
qualité lorsqu'elle est fondée
lorsqu'elle est vérifiée non seulement
elle prend à la fois plus de temps à
être produites mais aussi plus de temps
à être diffusé et je pense que cette
notion de temps long pour beaucoup de
choses est associé à un temps de
réflexion à un temps de débat et un
temps d'échange le temps pouvant être
décliné sous toutes ses formes la
science et je pense que c'est très bien
comme ça est exigeante elle est
rigoureuse elle est précise et elle est
réfléchie elle ne s'accommode pas de
petits arrangements de petits raccourcis
elle ne transige pas avec la vérité et
je pense que cela pourrait être
décourageant parfois mais l'on peut se
demander comment lutter contre cette
asymétrie et notre supérieur représentés
aujourd'hui par les étudiants et les
étudiantes représentent un enseignement
adossé à la recherche et donc pour moi
c'est important parce que adossait à une
certaine esprit critique à une certaine
échange et à une certaine méthodologie
scientifique qui va aussi et qui
participe à tout ce que l'on essaye
d'inculquer et tout ce qui finalement
aujourd'hui résonne ici dans ce lieu
emblématique sur cela je crois qu'en
mettant tout en oeuvre pour rendre
accessible au plus grand nombre au plus
grand nombre et cette égalité des
connaissances et des avancées des
sciences et bien ça passe évidemment par
la diffusion la diffusion pardon
scientifique mais aussi par le rôle que
nous devons à la parole scientifique
dans le débat public et dans le débat
politique et à cette diversité des
profils
évidemment je crois profondément et plus
encore dans le contexte actuel que nous
avons besoin de ces initiatives de ces
événements qui nous rassemblent et qui
permettent effectivement de tisser de
renforcer de renforcer des liens en
particulier en tracadémie intellectuel
média les élus les décideurs publics et
les décideurs privés et bien sûr la
société civile et les citoyens
d'aujourd'hui et de demain on peut même
parler des citoyens d'hier on l'a vu
tout à l'heure et que certains des
ouvrages sélectionnés et vraiment je
vous en rends hommage on refait revivre
revivre le temps d'une lecture mais qui
est très présent dans nos mémoires je
suis heureuse aussi de voir les
étudiants consacrés de leur temps à la
lecture des ouvrages sélectionnés à
sélectionner sur ces ouvrages sur ses
événements politiques qui racontent qui
agissent du procès des attentat 13
novembre qui a comme le lauréat V13 qui
je rends hommage la BD lauréate sur ma
liste ou c'est Kin ou bien bien sûr des
ouvrages sur le combat le combat mené
par Gisèle Halimi à qui je rends aussi
hommage le récit d'une campagne
présidentielle de l'art et de la
nécessité du débat et je sais au combien
ces auteurs en sont friand et aussi
portent hausse débat mais aussi sur la
manière dont ces événements sont
racontés c'est-à-dire sur la plume des
auteurs ou des dessinateurs sur le
rythme du récit sur la manière dont les
auteurs parviennent à saisir le lecteur
car au-delà du plaisir personnel cette
lecture la lecture et peut aussi devenir
une aventure collective de ces
émulations sur notre passé plus ou moins
lointain plus ou moins proche peuvent
naître effectivement de nouvelles idées
nous avons besoin absolument de ces
nouvelles idées pour construire demain
la vie des jeunes lecteurs des étudiants
et des étudiantes qui ont comme grande
mission et ce sont eux les acteurs de
demain pour changer le monde nous est
effectivement tellement précieux c'est
bien à vous
qu'appartiendra demain et déjà
aujourd'hui de changer ce monde de
répondre à tous les grands défis
auxquels nous devons faire face dès
aujourd'hui mais auquel vous allez faire
face demain et vous apporterez des
changements et des solutions le futur
c'est vous qui allez le construire et
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il est
important et vous le savez d'écouter de
vous écouter attentivement n'écouter ce
que vous avez à dire des événements
passés et dont vous vous servez comme
alimentation de toutes ces lectures
comme des plus récents de notre histoire
et je dirais de notre histoire
collective aux organisateurs de ce bel
événement je voudrais dire
particulièrement un grand merci pour
cette édition 2023 et toutes les autres
bien sûr je pense sincèrement que
susciter l'envie de libre et pour moi
aujourd'hui qui n'arrive plus à le faire
et donc c'est une frustration énorme
vrai pour l'accès au débat d'idée
contribuer à renforcer ce lien ce lien
si important entre les citoyens et nos
institutions et bien merci parce que ce
sont des entreprises des entreprises si
précieuses que nous devons continuer
coûte que coûte et continuer à
encourager je voudrais profiter
évidemment de remercier
dans ce lieu madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale pour l'accueil au
sein de cette Assemblée nationale je
pense que c'est précieux que ces
symbolique que c'est juste le pilier
essentiel de notre démocratie je suis
fière d'être auprès de Géraldine pour la
fin de ce jury et je voudrais finir pour
dire aux étudiants membres du jury un
grand merci non seulement merci pour ces
décisions toujours difficiles à prendre
je le vois par rapport à la liste finale
mais aussi pour votre implication votre
curiosité votre intérêt
la façon dont vous avez montré cet
esprit critique et cette pertinence pour
vos regards précieux je voudrais bien
sûr remercier tous les auteurs pour ces
leur contributions diverses leur
contribution riche et toutes de grandes
qualités comme il est à Teddy et puis au
lauréat juste un mot je crois leur dire
merci et bravo je vous remercie à tous
et c'est un honneur d'être là
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame la Ministre merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis sur LCP merci
Cédric Lewandowski pour l'organisation
de cette magnifique 32e journée du Livre
politique de l'Assemblée nationale est
restée bien évidemment sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]